le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
pour profiter pleinement de sa retraite
mieux vaut être en bonne santé mais
passer les 60 ans après une vie à
travailler les petits mots font surface
les visites sur le docteur sont plus
fréquentes la consommation de
médicaments augmente et les analyses
médicales deviennent régulières la
sécurité sociale ne prend pas en charge
l'intégralité des frais médicaux mais
pour certaines personnes
les soins sont indispensables pour être
en meilleure santé et quand on a une
petite retraite c'est parfois compliqué
alors comment se soigner sans se mettre
en difficulté financière
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
c'est à saint-andré que vie marie lucas
à 60 ans passés elle essaye de profiter
au mieux de sa petite retraite comme
beaucoup de personnes de son âge elle
doit régulièrement rendre visite à son
médecin traitant acheter des médicaments
ou bien faire des analyses et examens
divers la sécurité sociale ne pouvant
pas rembourser tous les frais médicaux
marie lucas et son mari sont obligés de
prendre une mutuelle mais à leur âge les
prix des mutuelles sont très élevés une
dépense difficile à assumer pour la
petite retraite de marie lucas le couple
de retraités et malheureusement obligés
de se serrer la ceinture pour continuer
à assurer les frais médicaux
indispensables à leur santé
au cours d'une discussion avec des amis
marie lucas apprend qu'elle peut
bénéficier du chèque santé un dispositif
à l'initiative de nassimah dindar
présidente du conseil général qui lui
permet de payer sa mutuelle pour elle et
son mari après avoir appris cette
nouvelle elle est allée directement aux
départements pour enclencher les
démarches et j'ai payé beaucoup en temps
et depuis à l'âge de 60 ans je paye la
mutuelle sans être remboursés la
démarche c'était très facile c'était au
conseil général
ils m'ont dit de ramener des papiers
aux comme je paye pas d'impôt sur le
revenu je ramenais s'abat avec les
documents qui vient de la mairie ces
données sont si tôt c'était c'était
facile à faire il fallait savoir
en arrivant là bas et mon chum la
demande est tout petit j'étais accordé
qui aime bien en a fait assez c'est eux
qui font tout bouge ps reçoit les 30
euros ça me soulage énormément pour la
mutuelle c'est à dire quand je dis le
chèque santé pour moi c'est 30 euros et
pour mon mari également ça aide beaucoup
comme on n'a pas une grosse retrait il
faut quand même payer à mutuel avec le
chèque santé je me sens très bien avec
j'essaie de m'en sortir
et c'est très facile à faire il ya
beaucoup de vieilles personnes qui
savent pas qu'ils ont droit au chèque
santé
moi je savais pas jusqu'à l'année
dernière
et maintenant que je sais mais ça m'aide
beaucoup cela fait maintenant deux ans
que marie luc un pays sa mutuelle avec
le chèque santé elle est plus à l'aise
financièrement et peut profiter un peu
mieux de sa petite retraite avec son
mari tout en continuant de préserver sa
santé grâce à cette aide proposée par le
conseil général beaucoup de réunionnais
peuvent entrer dans le troisième âge
avec plus de sérénité et moins
d'inquiétude la santé de nos bons
gramoune c'est pas un luxe à la réunion
d'abord parce que les gens ont beaucoup
travaillé dès 60 ans ils peuvent
bénéficier du chèque santé je le répète
pour crise et les meilleures conditions
de vie et aussi
d'autonomie pour le maintien à domicile
une personne seule qui touchent jusqu'à
973 euros seules elles peuvent
bénéficier du chèque santé du conseil
général et pour deux personnes mille
quatre cent soixante euros si vous
n'avez pas encore obtenu le chèque santé
du conseil général n'hésitez pas fait la
demande vous serez bénéficiaires
le chèque santé existe depuis 2007 et
évolue chaque année pour répondre le
mieux possible aux besoins des
réunionnais troisième âge il vient
d'être encore simplifiée puisque il est
désormais attribué pour trois ans et non
plus une seule année sa reconduction est
automatique en aidant les personnes
âgées dans leur quotidien le conseil
général participe pleinement à la
transmission du patrimoine réunionnais
mais aussi à la prévention de la
dépendance et au maintien au domicile
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais